la tensión entre Perú y Colombia ha
escalado hasta el punto que el viernes
el congreso peruano declaró persona no
ingrata al presidente Gustavo Petro el
punto de la discordia un comentario del
mandatario colombiano criticando la
acción policial peruana en las protestas
contra el gobierno en Perú los policías
marchan como nazis contra su propio
pueblo rompiendo la convención americana
de los Derechos Humanos la medida contra
Petro que ha apoyado al expresidente
Pedro Castillo desde que salió del Poder
y no ha reconocido a Dina boluarte como
presidenta prohíbe el presidente de
izquierdas volver a pisar Perú e implica
un quiebre en las relaciones bilaterales
entre Colombia y Perú yo desde acá le
digo al señor Petro que yo que se
dedique a gobernar Colombia que también
sus calles están llenando de protestas y
que nos deja a nosotros los peruanos
resolver las nuestras no obstante pese
al enfado de Lima el presidente
colombiano no ha sido el único que ha
señalado compo rtamientos inapropiados
por parte de la policía peruana en el
marco de las manifestaciones que exigen
elecciones anticipadas y la división de
Dina boluarte en el país andino amnistía
internacional acusó a las autoridades de
hacer un uso ilegítimo de armas contra
civiles
con un sesgo racista y clasista
especialmente contra los indígenas el
número de muertes arbitrarias por la
represión estatal se encuentra
concentrado de manera desproporcionada
en regiones con población
mayoritariamente de pueblos indígenas
por el mismo motivo el gobierno de Perú
también ha tenido tensiones con otros
países de la región como México o
Bolivia